you're struggling to understand why some
people are vaccine hesitant let me help
you
[Music]
imagine you're a normal person the years
2016. rightly or wrongly you believe
most of what you see in the media
you believe polls are broadly reflective
of public opinion
you believe doctors and scientists are
trustworthy and independent
you're a decent reasonable person who
follows the rules and trusts Authority
imagine you shock them when brexit which
you were assured won't happen because
it's a fringe movement led by racists
for racists happens
the poles which widely predicted it
wouldn't happen were completely wrong
the experts and media pundits who told
you it wouldn't happen day after day are
also wrong
oh well you say these things happen
imagine that soon after Donald Trump is
running for president
you're told by your favorite media
Publications that he is going to lose
some experts say his opponent has a 99
chance of winning
imagine waking up on the morning after
the election to discover that pollsters
media experts and politicians you still
trusted were wrong again
and now the racist monster they told you
would never get near the White House is
the leader of the Free World
how did this happen you ask yourself how
could all the people in charge of
informing me be so wrong
it was the Russians they tell you the
Russians did brexit and they got Trump
elected too
imagine that for the next three and a
half years you watch as the media and
the political class run with the Russia
collusion narrative they tell you the
how the when the where the dossiers the
whistleblowers the peeing prostitutes
imagine your desperation for things to
make sense again
the Mueller report is coming and it will
set your world straight evidence of
foreign meddling in the 2016 election
and brexit is coming to save you
unsettled mind
imagine you're shocked then when you
discover that brexit and Trump had
little to do with foreign meddling the
screaming about Russians and brexit dies
down as well
imagine the bit by bit you discover that
events which the media and political
class told you would not and could not
happen not only happen but happen
without some sort of evil interference
instead millions of your fellow citizens
voted for them again you ask how could
this happen and again the media has the
answer racism your country is racist
they tell you if you're white they seems
strange to you other than a handful of
idiots you've never met a racist
if you're an ethnic minority immigrant
like me this seems even stranger why
would people and one of the most
welcoming tolerant countries in the
world want to convince themselves their
country is racist when it's obviously
not
but the evidence is right there on your
TV screen
imagine your horror as a gay black actor
is assaulted by Marga hat wearing Thugs
who racially abuse him and put a noose
around his neck he cries while talking
about it
imagine your outrage as you've seen news
reports of a bunch of Maga hat wearing
kids from a religious school
contemptuously confront a Native
American Elder
Reza Aslan tells you the kid has a
punchable face and while you're a poor
Violet it's hard to disagree
imagine that for days you watch coverage
of these events with expert after expert
pundit after pundit sharing and fueling
your outrage about them with every word
your belief that you're a good person
and that your country is a good country
waivers
imagine that soon after however the
juicy smaller story turns out to be an
attention-seeking hoax
imagine that you quickly discovered that
the Native American Elder was the one
who confronted the kids and not the
other way around
if this is such a racist country you ask
yourself why would they need to make up
stories of racism
as you Ponder this you remember that for
years now you've been expected to go
along with other Make-Believe
you're expected to believe that whether
you're male or female is not as simple
as you once thought whatever you learn
about biology at school is wrong
you no longer know how many genders
there are and it seems dangerous to try
and find out
imagine reading that the experts at the
American Psychological Association say
that traditional masculinity is
pathological and harmful
imagine that you still want to believe
the media and their experts but now that
requires you to think your country is
racist men are bad and gender is a
social construct whatever that means
it is at this point that a pandemic
emerges on the other side of the world
you're initially unconcerned but as
scenes emerge from Italy and other
countries it is clear that something big
is happening you watch nervously as
politicians give press conference after
press conference flanked by experts to
explain the situation
the racist Donald Trump shuts down
travel from China
in response the mayor of Florence in
Italy advises citizens to fight racism
by hugging a Chinese person
shortly after Nancy Pelosi a respected
Democrat visits Chinatown and San
Francisco to explain that there's no
reason tourists or local should be
staying away from the area because of
coronavirus concerns
thank God there are some sensible
non-racist people who aren't
overreacting you say to yourself
imagine watching As Trump doubles down
on his racism by claiming the virus may
have come from a lab in Wuhan nonsense
you think to yourself as you wonder how
best to protect yourself and your family
from this deadly disease you consider
getting masks you've seen visitors from
Asian countries wear them
but the UK's chief medical officer tells
you not to wear a mask and to wash your
hands instead
as lockdowns are introduced around the
world you diligently follow all the
rules you stay at home only go out once
a day live off savings or government
grants
you're proud to be doing your part
thanks to you and millions of your
fellow citizens the first wave of the
pandemic does not overwhelm the Health
Care system while thousands sadly die
you've helped to protect the NHS
imagine your confusion as the same
people who have spent three months
telling you Mars don't work and you
shouldn't wear them then introduce Mass
mandate we're following the science they
tell you this makes little sense but a
pandemic is no time for questions
as you cautiously go to the supermarket
you notice that must have made people
far less likely to socially distance
you remember reading somewhere the
bicycle helmets work the same way they
give the wearer more confidence and the
result is more accidents and injuries
nor fewer
silly people you say to yourself if only
they would just follow government advice
you turn on your TV to learn that
Shoppers at your local supermarket
aren't the only ones who have been
ignoring the rules Neil Ferguson the man
whose projections were used as the basis
for lockdowns appears to have broken his
own rules to get some action with his
married lover
Boris Johnson's Chief advisor Dominic
Cummings drove halfway across the
country to ensure he had a better place
to isolate
the journalists who berate him for this
are later found to have attended a
birthday party in breach of the rules
the lockdown continues
however a man is killed in Minneapolis
while being arrested for a petty crime
the man is black the officer is why
the arrest is captured on video and
quickly goes viral around the world
imagine your horror as you watch an
officer of the law kneel on another
man's neck until he passes out and later
dies
this is disgusting you say to yourself I
hope they throw the book at him
overnight a huge campaign for racial
Justice Springs up around the world
no one explains what racism had to do
with the incident but they don't need to
as you know by now the West is racist
and therefore anytime a white person
does anything bad to a black person
there can be only one explanation
the fact that an identical incident
happened to a white man called Tony
Timber is never mentioned for context
while the lockdown rules remain in place
the protests against Injustice spill out
onto the street
tens of thousands of people crowned into
major cities
few where Mars and social distancing is
non-existent
clashes with police ensue and in America
protesters loot stores attack residents
and start fires
a retired black police officer called
David Dawn is among dozens of people who
are murdered in the chaos
the media described these events as
mostly peaceful protests as the
reporters stand in front of burning
buildings
after months of harsh restrictions the
media and political class offer no
criticism of protests which violate
every element of lockdown after months
of telling you to stay at home to avoid
spreading covert doctors explain that
rather than being a mass covered
spreading event protest is a profound
Public Health intervention
[Music]
big tech companies go into overdrive to
stop the spread of disinformation all
discussion of alternative points of view
regarding the efficacy of mass and
lockdowns as well as the origins of the
virus are censored
attempts to discuss the negative impact
of lockdown on health and mental
well-being are suppressed
as the year runs on with a pivotal
American election looming president
Trump promises a huge push to develop a
vaccine
Kamala Harris who was later elected vice
president says that she would not take
the vaccine if Trump told her to
on the eve of the election a publication
in America releases a damaging report
about Hunter Biden son of presidential
candidate Joe Biden the story alleges
corruption which may involve his father
as well as drug-taking use of
prostitutes and more
Twitter and other social media companies
prevent the story from being shared the
media lines up commentators to claim the
story was Russian disinformation
once his father wins the election it
becomes clear that several key elements
of the story are likely accurate and the
laptop from which the information was
recovered is in fact Hunter Biden's
laptop
meanwhile the numbers of covert patients
and deaths turn out to have been wrong
for some time anyone who died at any
point after a positive covert test was
counted as dying of covert even if they
were killed by a drunk driver
these figures later revised again the
number of people who are in hospital
because of covet also turns out to be
incorrect
now that racist Donald Trump is no
longer president closing borders is no
longer considered xenophobic and is
widely advocated for in the media
the racist conspiracy theory that the
virus came from a lab in China is now
also allowed to be discussed and appears
likely to be the most credible
explanation of the origins of the virus
imagine your horror as you learned that
the reason thousands of people died in
the first wave of the pandemic was that
elderly patients with covid were allowed
to be released back into care hunt
this is especially true in the UK and in
New York run by Governor Andrew Cuomo
brother of CNN anchor Chris Cuomo
Governor Cuomo publisher suspends
promotion of his book about leadership
during the pandemic amid the inquiring
to nursing home deaths meanwhile Texas
and Florida which remained open continue
to thrive
in the UK the health secretary the
person responsible for saving lives is
found to be cheating on his wife with a
married aide in breach of social
distancing guidelines
the man making the rules for you does
not follow them
it is at this point that the vaccine
which you were initially told would need
to be given to the vulnerable before
restrictions can be lifted becomes the
main Drive of government policy and
media commentary the same people who
told you brexit would never happen Trump
would never win that when he did win it
was because of Russian collusion then
because of racism that you must follow
lockdown rules while they don't The
Masks don't work and then that they do
the protest during lockdowns are a
health intervention the ransacking black
communities in the name of fighting
racism as mostly peaceful Justice the
Justice smaller was a victim of a hate
crime but men are toxic that there is an
infinite number of genders that covert
didn't come from a lab and then that it
probably did the closing borders is
racist and then that it's the most
important thing to do that the hunter
Biden stories Russian disinformation and
then that it's not that they would not
take Trump's vaccine and then that you
must take the vaccine the Governor Cuomo
is a great covert leader and then that
he is a granny killer and a sex path
that the number of covert is one thing
and then another
the hospitals are filled with covert
patients and then that many of them
caught covered in hospital
these are the same people now telling
you the vaccine is safe you must take it
and if you don't you will be a second
class citizen
understand vaccine hesitancy now
how do I know all this
here on trigonometry we have honest
conversations with people who can
actually explain why things are
happening join us